the Mt Mac Mini is one of the best deals
in Computing ever but unfortunately
Apple limited it so how much money do
you need to spend to get excellent
performance and is it worth upgrading to
the M2 Pro and with that specking it up
to get much better performance well
today we're going to show you guys a
bunch of different tests let me show you
the full differences depending on how
much you're going to spend and tell you
what I would suggest buying depending on
what you do now right of the get-go we
have a 599 dollar Mac Mini that's even
cheaper the student discount we have a
999 we have a 12.99 and a 17.99 the base
pack has eight gigs of RAM and 512 SSD
and then going up I switched to 16 gigs
of ram in 512. now with the M2 Pro we
have 512 with 16 gigs as well and then
jumping up to one terabyte and having
the full unbined M2 Pro chip the first
thing that I have to tell you is that
unfortunately with these M2 series of
products the base SSD is always about
half the speed compared to upgrading to
a higher capacity now with the base M2
Mac Mini it is much slower and then with
the M2 Pro once again you have to go up
to one terabyte if you want the full
performance now the numbers seem like a
big difference but when you go and
transfer large files that base model
will really slow down because of SLC
caching so I would say if you can afford
it at least get 512 and we'll see if
that faster SSD with one terabyte makes
a real world difference now on the
positive side all of these machines even
the cheapest one comes with Wi-Fi 6E and
Bluetooth 5.3 which give them really
fast speeds if you have fast internet
even compared to my 15 000 Mac Pro these
new ones are much quicker if you guys
want to find out more about this I did a
super detailed video on these internet
speeds and some potential issues as far
as general computing I use geekbench 6
to test out the CPU and for single core
score the M2 Pro is only slightly faster
than the M2 Chip in looking at
multi-core we don't get a boost from the
base model upping the RAM and SSD but
from the base 10 core M2 Pro going up to
12 core we do see a difference now if we
look at the very cheapest one going all
the way up to eighteen hundred dollars
the difference is only roughly 43 44
percent so for most users you won't
notice that much of a difference and
will look at tougher tasks soon now for
web browsing and web-based applications
using speedometer 2.0 you see that we
get a little bit more performance at the
higher end ones but once again not that
big of a difference and that's because a
lot of this is very simple easy tasks so
if you're somebody that just wants to do
email and web browsing even the base
model will do a good job for tougher
web-based applications like our web
design test using figma with this
project that's provided by 500 designs
one of the best Design Studios in La as
far as smoothness it is very very
similar across the board and when I went
ahead and I rendered this 12 hi-res page
website the differences were noticeable
but once again not startling so because
this uses a variety of different
resources I would say if you do web
design you don't need to spend that
extra money for music production we use
logic to test with our new logic pro
Benchmark you guys can look in the
details and as far as the tracks the M2
Pro will actually do more than double so
you do get your money's worth now it
depends on how many plugins you use but
you definitely get extra performance and
the one thing I would say is even though
the test doesn't show the difference
between 8 gig and 16 if you're using a
lot of plugins you definitely want to
have at least 16 gigs of RAM now with
the M2 Chip you can actually go up to 24
and the M2 2 Pro allows you up to 32. if
you guys want to see the differences we
actually have videos comparing 8 versus
16 16 versus 24 on the M2 Chip and then
also with them to Pro so search our
Channel and you guys can check that out
a lot of those are using laptops but the
chips are the same now as far as coding
we tested out xcode and we saw a pretty
linear gain in terms of performance now
the M2 Chip is a eight core and then Mt
Pro is either a 10 or a 12 but what you
have to remember is the M2 Chip has four
performance cores and four efficiency
whereas the M2 Pro focuses more on extra
performance scores so we're seeing a
pretty decent difference here so if you
do a lot of compiling it's worth
spending the extra money and that is
directly related to the CPU performance
so we tested out cinebench R23 you guys
see the scores here both of the M2 chips
they have the same Prof performance
because the cores don't change but with
the M2 Pro the full unbin one you get
over 14 000 it's excellent CPU
performance now with that it does use
more power as well we took one of these
apart you guys saw the insides and the
M2 Chip one actually has a better
cooling system now you might be
wondering does that mean that it gets a
lot hotter well none of these have
issues with fan noise Apple allows them
to run a little bit hotter but they stay
silent what about graphics performance
the M2 Chip has 10 Graphics cores Apple
doesn't limit you with that one so
looking at geekbench's metal the scores
are almost the same even though we have
more RAM but the M2 Pro that one gets 73
000 which are very good scores now you
guys see that the scores aren't doubled
on the way up and what surprised me is
that spending the extra 300 bucks for
the more CPU and Graphics cores you'd
only get that much extra performance and
overall compute but we'll see how that
applies to other Graphics tasks now I
tested out gaming performance using 3D
Marks Wildlife extreme and here the 1300
M2 Pro gets almost double the
performance for 300 bucks more and
having the same amount of RAM and SSD
which is great but spending extra money
gives you just a little bit more once
again so if you play games I don't think
it's really worth it now for those of
you guys that do 3D rendering using
blender testing out the BMW project the
most expensive Mac Mini was more than
twice as fast as the M2 Chip models
which have the same Graphics cores but
the 1300 model was further behind than I
expect did so for these kind of tasks
having more Graphics chords is really
worth it now as far as photo editing
with Lightroom classic the highest end
Mac Mini was about twice as fast as the
base model and the 1300 r one wasn't far
behind for these kind of tasks now we're
using both CPU and GPU and the M2 Pro is
just really quick now one thing I want
to know is that this test here is not
using a lot of multitasking if you have
that base 599 model with 8 gigs of RAM
if you start multitasking you go from a
minute and 16 seconds all the way up to
5 minutes and 10 seconds whereas
multitasking if you have 16 gigs of RAM
doesn't really slow anything down so you
want to keep that in mind and then the
system stutters just like we've shown
using the same chip in the M2 MacBook
Air and MacBook Pro so if you do photo
editing please get at least 16 gigs of
RAM now I also tested out Photoshop
doing a panorama here and the M2 Pros
are very fast particularly the full 12
core CPU model it does this task in 48
seconds which is very quick now here's
where you have to ask yourself how much
faster do you need because even the M2
Chip with 16 gigs of RAM is very quick
for most people it is more than enough
unless you're making money or you're
working through a lot of files you don't
have to have the best spec getting into
video editing I stabilized a one minute
habc clip with Final Cut and the
difference scales fairly linearly all of
this is very quick for stabilization and
you do get extra benefits having those
extra graphic scores now in terms of
editing standard 4K footage all of these
do a great job and even though you can't
see the diff difference here with speeds
they're all identical if you have 16
gigs of RAM you can have larger projects
open whereas the a gig will start to
slow down and stutter which you don't
want now if we look at DaVinci Resolve
doing the same test everything does get
faster and the highest end one is
slightly faster now why are the speeds
so similar other than 8 gig being a bit
slower well it's because all of these
use the same encoder chip that's based
on the M2 so as far as exporting you
don't see much of a difference it's only
if you start doing heavier effects this
is where our graded Pro acid Pros raw
project comes in there's a lot of
effects a lot of processing and you see
that the 8 gig model is really quite
slow and if you spend more money you do
get faster now that 8 gig model if
you're multitasking that goes from 3
minutes 47 to 7 minutes and 14. it slows
your whole system down dramatically so
you definitely want the extra Ram once
again if you do video editing I would
spend the extra money in editing red raw
footage we see a massive difference the
most expensive Mac Mini is basically
three times faster compared to the base
one and the prices kind of match up as
well and even just upgrading your RAM
gets you a nice boost now one difference
that's not too massive is spending
thirteen hundred dollars compared to
spending eighteen hundred just like you
saw before the difference has been
fairly minimal when we have actually
seen it now I also denoise some
Blackmagic raw 4K footage and here we
see the playback speed the two base Mac
minis are the same then we go up to 6
FPS and then the highest end one with
the full 19 choreographics only goes up
to seven from six not a big difference
in raw performance and this is looking
at also how much different effects these
systems can handle tool so this being
the last test I will say that for a lot
of people I think that the Thirteen
hundred dollar spec where you have 512
gigs of SSD which is still fast you have
16 gigs of RAM which is enough and
having the extra performance of the M2
Pro is a great sweet spot when you start
spending eighteen hundred dollars yes
you now have one terabyte of twice as
fast SSD but that's where you start
getting into the Mac Studio which is
right there in terms of price and it has
a lot of other extra features and
capabilities so I have a full dedicated
video on this if you guys want to see it
I'll link it at the end but I think the
sweet spot is somewhere between that 800
to a thousand depending on your SSD
definitely get 16 gigs of RAM first in
my opinion now or get that 1300 spec now
we also have a few other differences
between the M2 and M2 Pro that I wanted
to save for last the M2 Pro supports
more displays and higher resolutions and
refresh rates which is great now it also
has four Thunderbolt ports instead of
two so when you're going from a thousand
dollars to thirteen hundred you're
getting a lot of extra benefits
including the performance so personally
if I was buying one I think that 12.99
for those that do a lot of different
productivity and creative tasks is an
awesome sweet spot I would just not
recommend the base model for those of
you guys that are watching this these
videos you want it to last for many
years and you want to make sure it
doesn't slow down when you are
multitasking if you guys have any other
questions go ahead and comment down
below click that button above to
subscribe and check out one of the ram
videos right there and the comparison to
the Mac Studio the spin Max and I'll see
you in the next one
[Music]